postdamer platz à berlin des dizaines de
manifestants sont venus exprimer leur
soutien à l'opposition biélorusse sur
leurs pancartes
ils dénoncent particulièrement la
répression policière que subissent les
détracteurs du président alexandre
loukachenko
certains se sont même couverts de faux
sang pour en marquer la brutalité même
rassemblement de soutien devant
l'ambassade de biélorussie en les tenues
dans la capitale riga drapeau pancartes
et fleurs à la main les manifestants se
montre parfois très ému là encore il
dénonce les violences à l'encontre des
opposants biélorusses rassemblements à
kiev également des manifestants se sont
donné rendez vous devant l'ambassade de
biélorussie en ukraine
certains sont venus avec des
photographies d'opposants molesté par la
police d'autres ont déposé des fleurs
rouges et blanches des couleurs qui
symbolise la lutte pour la démocratie
dans la bi lo russie voisine